I couldn't sleep that night I remember
thinking I'm all alone and then I
realized I had nothing to hide
there you are I just decided I wasn't
gonna be afraid
[Music]
when they assigned her to me
it was my idea to send her to Iran get
her into the nuclear division her cover
an English and French teacher I'm
probably not gonna sleep tonight I'm
gonna do right you're the best person
for this assignment did you know she was
cracking she had no idea great so what
do you do
haven't you learned not to ask questions
like that
the people here all have many secrets
you gonna tell me what's going on
she disappeared disappeared she could be
anywhere now we couldn't control her she
wanted to make that point there's much
more going on I'll handle it
I don't think you should get into this
need to find a way to bring him here
what is going on man
you wouldn't understand follow your
protocols assuming you know everything
but you don't this is war and in war
people die
[Music]
are you pulling me out
you